fred samo bonjour bonjour vous êtes
candidat aux élections législatives où
vous présenter dans la circonscription
du centre sur la liste bâtir le pays
martinique
alors pourquoi êtes vous candidat à ce
scrutin sur la liste bâtir le pays
martinique et l'alliance d'une partie de
l'alliance je suis candidat il s'agit
pour moi la de la poursuite de mon
engagement ce que j ai pas au co
associatif 17 ans de présidence à
l'étoile de gondeau est aussi un
parcours politique depuis 2004 je suis
conseiller municipal à la ville du
lamentin aujourd'hui je suis président
de la commission d'amm d'urbanisme
développement durable à la ville du
lamentin et je suis vice-président la
cacem et j'occupe le poste en tout cas
la fonction de président de la
commission d'aménagement de territoire
donc il s'agit pour moi la poursuite de
mon engagement au service dé martinique
quels seront les deux ou trois projets
prioritaires pour la martinique que vous
comptez défendre si vous êtes élu à
l'assemblée nationale via un des projets
prioritaires qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la politique publique
me n'est pas cadrée par l'économie comme
vous savez l'activité prégnante c'est le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat et la
cherté de la vie donc qu'un de mes
projets c'est de pouvoir passer
aujourd'hui nous avons l'observatoire
des prix de passer de l'observatoire des
prix à une vraie véritable commission de
régulation des prix avec véritable
pouvoir notamment un pouvoir coercitif
pour pouvoir attribuer des malus pour
celles et ceux qui ne respectent pas les
prix qui ont été définis il y aurait une
autre priorité que vous envisagez pour
le territoire oui vous voyez ma
circonscription et est concernée par le
phénomène de la sargasse
aujourd'hui nous avons des mesures des
financements pour le curatif pour les
prélèvements les maires qui sont
concernés ils donnaient tout toute leur
énergie mais moi je propose que à part
le curatif il faut qu'on réfléchisse sur
les recherches et développement de façon
à gasques la sargasse soit une matière
première il faut qu'on puisse développer
le financement pour donner notamment aux
jeunes martiniquais on a des jeunes
martiniquais qui sont par le monde qui
sont compétents que ces jeunes là
puissent revenir dans les territoires
concrets sous une structure capable de
les accueillir financer cette structure
de façon à ce qu'on fasse une recherche
pour que la série soit demain une
matière première vous parlez finalement
de la mise en place d'une filière
vraiment de revalorisation c'est ça une
filière de revalorisation en connexion
bien sûr avec avec les autres pays parce
que la lentille nick ne n'est pas le
seul pays qui est concerné par le
phénomène de la saga donc une filière de
revalorisation aujourd'hui nous savons
que la sargasse on peut faire du papier
il ya même on peut faire aussi des
montures mais s'agit de développer tout
cela pour aller plus loin sur la
recherche alors vous avez commencé à
parler effectivement de la
circonscription du centre avec frappé
par le phénomène des sargasses qui
touche aussi d'autres que d'autres
d'autres zones de notre territoire mais
si l'on doit parler de la
circonscription dans laquelle vous
présenter le centre quels sont selon
vous les deux ou trois priorités sur
lesquelles vous comptez plancher oui les
priorités que je à part lever la
politique en matière de la santé qui
concerne pas que la circonscription il
s'agit d'accompagner le mieux vieillir
de nos personnes âgées il s'agit aussi
de réduire l'inégalité sociale et
territoriale dans leur foi de soins
classé un sujet prégnant un sujet qui
est porté par la politique publique
défendues au niveau de la cité m et moi
en tant que député je devrais accompagné
en lien bien sûr avec la politique de la
cité m accompagner et d'une facilité en
tout cas s'il faut légiférer s'il faut
ouvrir taper sur la porte de ministres
créer les conditions pour que les les
mesures qui sont arrêtés au niveau de la
martinique soit accompagnée soient
prises en compte au niveau du national
frais de ces mots qu'avez vous à dire
aux électeurs
et lecteurs et lectrices de la
circonscription
qui dura première circonscription de la
martinique à savoir le gone la trinité
le robert lefrançois et le lamentin la
situation de la martinique tu exiges
pour nous élus qu'on ait une obligation
de résultat et cette obligation de
résultat parce passe par l'efficacité
l'efficacité les conditions pour les
effets que l'efficacité il faut que vous
ayez un élu qui soit l'acte il est un
élu compétent un élu qui est de la
constance il faut aussi que con que vous
aidiez un élu qui soient ancrés sur son
territoire il faut que l'élu soit à
proximité soit en iran avec son
territoire et enfin pour l'efficacité il
faut que cet élu potes les politiques
publiques qui sont décidés au niveau de
la martinique il faut que cet élu soit
en cohérence avec cette politique
publique il soit cohérent de façon à les
défendre au niveau national donc oui la
compétence la rectitude de la constance
la cohérence et l'ancrage territorial
mois fritz hameau g can toutes ces
conditions si pour ça que je vous
appelle dès le 11 à mobiliser vos amis
mobiliser votre famille dès le 11 juin
prenez le bulletin frezza mots avec sa
suppléante josette manin egli le
bulletin dans l'urne merci fred chameau
merci
[Musique]